get back I'm gonna buy this off I'm 100
in for this
today is gonna be the best day ever I
love sunshine I love butterflies but
more than anything I love God
shut the up
that's Doug the
in the world
we're playing this game called fetching
he drops me off really far away
and drives home without me when I bring
the ball back he says that's how I know
I won the game
hey honey you ever been with an Afghan
before I don't think so much thank you
thank you for me kid he left your ass oh
that can't be right you are officially
astray that would mean
duck doesn't love me
poor little guy I should probably talk
to him I am a therapy dog
you can learn how beautiful it can be
when you're off the leash this beer is
making me dizzy he's about to get real
Dizzy up in this I'm having a great time
right here
what did you just say I really hate for
this to get violence
[Applause]
he needs to pay for what he did with the
only thing he truly loves I'm gonna bite
his oh wait did he just say I'm still a
little drunk but I said I'm gonna bite
his oh we go
big day today you ever humped anything
before I wouldn't say I've humped or
saved there you go red I'm doing good
tell him you're his daddy hey gnome I'm
your father it's good to finally meet
you right even under these strange
circumstances
completely lost and my little puppy paw
pads are really hurting right now so how
exactly could this get worse
guys we've got to rip off
what are those kind of looks like food
oh uh give me a second you look
different you look different too how so
is it my human hands
[Music]